i don't know what to do
i [ __ ] my best friend's mom
and
she
won't leave me a world now
and
now i don't know what to do about it
so
well i think it's a question what kind
of friend are you brother
you know you you know if you made love
to your buddy's mother of course she's
gonna like you
because if it's your best friend he
likes you you're best friends
so you're just you know
he came out of her so you're going back
to the
you know you're going back to the front
porch of his creation and
hanging out there
so yes the mother's gonna like you the
kid likes you
you know your buddy likes you so
i think you gotta just hit for the cycle
dude and be a damn stepdad brother
you know step up to the plate who else
you're gonna date you're gonna date
somebody across town
somebody that's working over there at
the dunkin donuts at the drive-through
or something
somebody that's you know
someone some weird person that when they
go to a restaurant they like fill their
hand up with like salt or sugar and dip
their finger in it while they're waiting
to eat dinner and lick it and then lick
the salt or sugar off
who are you gonna date somebody like
that
are you gonna date your best friend's
mom
and go in there and be a champion not
only for her but for your friend
imagine that
imagine one day you sit down with your
buddy and say hey man
i love you so much as a friend
that i'm gonna take care of your mother
for the rest of her life
when you come over i'm a grill for you
you know i'm gonna get i'm going to get
angry at you i'm going to [ __ ] make
you try and make you rake the yard
and i'm going to fist fight you in your
mother and i's own yard
what do you want
what does god want
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one